Sheep ... were not always woolly.
We have contributed to increasing their wool by encouraging more sheep to reproduce more in every generation
This is the domestication: modification of wild animals for better human use.
As we saw in Part I, for humans in ancient times, animals were powerful tools
... food, clothing, transport and tractors.
However, although there are animals everywhere, however, the domestication has been on a few in pre-modern times.
Why are these animals so domesticated?
What do you think we should create a list of requirements for the domestication?
First: Easy to feed
The cow is a machine turning the grass into a steak.
And the whole tiger turns the flesh into ... a tiger.
Ten pounds of grass produces a pound of flesh. Ten pounds of meat produce a pound of tiger.
... but the two results have the same number of calories - so just eating cow will save yourself a lot of work.
Therefore, carnivores will not breed, just because of thermodynamics.
Research is actually about animals eating the herbs available without conditions and complexity
What is required is that animals eat something that is abundantly available but humans do not consume it to eat
Animals and carnivores prefer not to require specific eating options and are well worth the effort
Generally, we put the pig before the fence because we first have to prose an animal ...
friendly
Well, obviously catching meat eaters is a bad idea anyway because their profession in life is murder.
But a lot of carnivores like bears enjoy killing.
There is no safety in vegetarians as well: buffaloes are terrifying tanks for all the reasons mentioned before ...
... Hippo is the biggest killer in Africa
... The giraffes look stupid / stupid until we notice the extent of their beatings, even the blacks often avoid them
Animals that seem easy to domesticate, are not coincidental because they are not dangerous
War bears are a great advantage for your tribe, but this will not happen.
If the animal is large and not dangerous, it is very tense!
Try to sneak on a gazelle? This joke "lol!"
Sure, you and your friends can spend a full day with their appendages until they get tired ...
... but if the gazelle does not break his neck himself while trying to drag him to your home
... He will jump and flee easily from the fence he built for him
In general, the following point: Some animals have - humming - a reproductive mood
Making them unfit for families. And we mean you Panda!
Time and energy spent by people to try to encourage panda to reproduce laughable!
Fishermen need an animal eager to reproduce, so much so that it tries to reproduce with the wrong things sometimes
... It is not an animal that requires us to closely follow their breeding seasons
So: friendly, easy to feed, and - affectionate.
It also needs to grow up quickly.
This leads us to the crucifixion of the subject of childbearing in exchange for grooming.
Again: Animal domestication is changing it to make it better for us.
And a side note here: we plant plants too.
They are so terribly rich / delicious from their wild origin
So when the hippie community talks about going back to nature, they forget that these plants are just like making a man like this.
Anyway, back to animals ...
The success of the pork conclusion project is that the generations of pigs are shorter than human generations. - 10 new pigs every four months -
One intelligent person can make progress in a pig project during his life
For comparison: Elephants.
Two years for young elephants, five years between births, nine years to female maturity, fifteen years for males?
This is a joke you elephants! We do not have time for this!
But humans can tame elephants. You capture Phil, and train him not to fear humans. Then use it for any purpose
But the elephants' domestication requires accurate records over several generations of humans ...
... Not to mention that tame one or two incredibly expensive elephants
... This is why the war vile is rare and only in complex and sophisticated societies.
The naughty elephants \ pet are of luxury, so this is the rule: if it is in a farm, it's domesticated \ domesticated, if in the circus, it is uncircumcised.
Finally: Families.
Well: Zebra compared to horses.
Horses have changed the course of civilizations. It is worth noting that from thousands of years BC to the Telegav ...
A man on horseback is considered the best internet available! (comunnication tool)
The horses were domesticated in Europe and Asia, but the beginning of humans was in Africa that had a zebra ...
Why did not the first man ride on the back of the zebra to invade the world?
Because the zebra is cursed. They live on kicking and biting: this is a danger in the pre-penicillin world. - Your hand is inflamed? nice to meet you :( -
The mulberry has a reactive reaction that is very difficult to catch.
In addition to being an abhorrent animal, zebra lacks a family structure.
Horse herds have a hierarchy - you can see that when they travel in a straight line: the male, then the female top, then her children, then the second female, her children, and so on.
When a man tames the head of a herd of horses, he imposes himself as the head of the new herd
Many domesticated animals are now domesticated, because humans have exploited their family pyramid
Animals breed and grow up with the principle that this man is somehow the head of the herd responsible ... no problem!
The chickens will click and click some of them until they are absorbed by the larger hen
But do you know who is the biggest chicken? We are the biggest chicken!
Dogs and cats: This is what makes them different.
Dogs will love you and defend you and hunt with you because you are part of the herd for them
Living dogs to be useful to us - this in our modern world means falling to pretend death! - But they love it!
"Excellent dog! Excellent dog!" [Laugh]
... while a cat is a small tiger living in your home.
Overall, back to these!
For the zebra, there is no such thing as a herd or community.
They live in groups just because it is an excellent way to survive and live. But they do not care about communities
Grab a zebra and you'll notice that his family will leave him, try to ride him and you will be lucky if you escaped your fingers!
Wild donkeys appear similar to horses from the outside, but different from the inside
So the requirements are: friendly - can be fed - and affection - family / social
It's not a big requirement, but for hunters, any animal they want to domesticate, it needs all the requirements
... This is why in the history of ancient man, only a limited number of large animals have been domesticated.
[Music] Translation by - سليمان العقل Review by -
This video is sponsored by audible.com.
If you like the menus like me ...
I recommend you to the book "The Checklist Manifesto" by author Atul Jawand
Yes really! There is a complete book on how important lists are and how much you will change your life ...
... and what types of lists are good and bad
... with examples from the airline field to times of war and even in your daily life
I highly recommend it.
Go to audible.com/grey to experience the site and hear "The Checklist Manifesto"
Audible contains 180,000 books waiting for you to listen to them, and I listen to books all the time to improve my life
Why not try it today through the Audible.com/grey link?
[Music]